dans cette petite fiole la promesse d'un
second vaccin iranien contre le coc vite
téhéran a dévoilé ce lundi sa stratégie
les essais cliniques du vaccin rasic off
parce qu'on sût à l'institut ghazi de
recherche sur les vaccins et les sérums
commenceront bientôt ils seront d'abord
réalisé sur treize volontaires âgés de
18 à 55 ans le vaccin doit obtenir
l'autorisation de l'autorité iranienne
pour les médicaments et l'alimentation
dès que le vaccin aura obtenu
l'autorisation nous prévoyons de
commencer les essais dans les prochains
jours une semaine au plus tard la
campagne de vaccination elle commence ce
mardi mais avec le vaccin russe spoutnik
v téhéran a fait un choix radical dans
sa stratégie vaccinale n'utiliser que
les doses venant de pays alliés comme la
russie les autres vaccins américains et
britanniques ont été interdits à
l'importation
le guide suprême ali khameini ne fait
pas confiance à ces pays rivaux la
population elle semble frileuse devant
l'arrivée du vaccin russa et si ce
vaccin est approuvée par l'organisation
mondiale de la santé bien sûr que nous
l'accueillerons car la situation du
coronavirus est très grave et
préoccupante j'espère qu'elle se
terminera bientôt
le vaccin est arrivé aujourd'hui en iran
mais je préfère ne pas le prendre je
n'ai pas confiance je préfère attendre
un an pour voir quels sont les effets et
quels sont les effets secondaires
je n'ai pas confiance pour le moment au
total l'iran a commandé deux millions de
doses de spoutnik v mais aussi 4,2
millions de doses de vaccins anglo
suédois astrazeneca les postures
diplomatiques s'efface finalement devant
l'urgence sanitaire selon le ministère
de la santé iranien le coc vide 19 a
fait plus de cinquante huit mille cinq
cents morts sur plus d'un million 400
mille personnes contaminées